Dakota is with us in Illinois Dakota
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show how can
Christy and I help you today
hey Dave yes I'm in Chicago you know why
first dance caller your baby steps for
about the past year and a half and it
kind of lets go
and thank you were not sitting out as
much right now it has not taken
seriously the emergency farmers and
suggest my question is pretty much how
to best use my time during this furlough
I just started yesterday I was given
that news so I pretty much like I have
boxes they did advise my unemployment
oxi but then I also know that there's a
couple grocery stores in the area you
know higher than usual and I could pick
up some hours there and so that's pretty
much like huh I guess I'm asking how to
navigate that because I'm you know I
might have like an ignorant stigma
towards no filing for unemployment not
really sure that's like it just started
a new career four months ago and this
happened so not sure if you know there's
a way which one I should do is better in
terms of like financially speaking or if
there's a way I can legally do both or
I'm not really sure you know what you
would recommend in that situation well
my understanding is if you make a
certain amount of money you no longer
qualify for unemployment because you've
gotten reemployed as the way it's viewed
so okay if I if I understand it
correctly and you can check on that
mathematically what you could do would
simply go okay unemployment page this
pays X can I make more doing something
other than unemployment and the answer
would usually be yes and so spiritually
emotionally physically I'd rather be
working even if I made about the same
money I'd rather be working it's not
just the stigma of it it's just activity
is good for you Nick Christine yeah it's
amazing to it's not just that it creates
this momentum in this season even though
the season is not what any of us would
have chosen
you're you're being active you're making
things happen you're controlling what
you can and you're creating momentum
that I think will carry you into the
next season even if you're not going to
be
in the next season what you are gonna do
to get through this one and one thing I
would encourage you is that you you have
more options than to Dakota so I would
just look at that like I never feel good
when I feel painted into a corner or
have one of two options I don't really
like I try to create like 25 or 30
options and then whatever I choose I'm
more confident in that choice because
I've compared it to a lot of things so I
would just encourage you to make a list
of all the different ways you could make
money during this time maybe you work
part-time and you have a side gig
part-time and maybe you you know I don't
know what that looks like for you but
you've got more options than to I would
just I would start by brainstorming a
lot of options and then choose the best
from there yeah all the grocery stores
are hiring all the targets and Amazons
and pizza deliveries are all hiring
hundreds of thousands of people are at
this moment and so you've got a lot of
options of that kind of thing what do
you do for a living what's your career
this floor must've got hired on with
enterprise rent-a-car I've been to the
training center level position and they
started moving up the ladder so I wanted
to kind of get furloughed for this time
no contract I'm just thinking do you
have some kind of skill set where you
create a unique side uh so the christy
is talking about and you can ask
yourself that question because that'll
usually pay more than target well pay or
Hamazon delivery will pay I mean you can
make that that whatever it is $17 $15 an
hour or whatever it is right now and you
can get more than that if you work a lot
of overtime and just you know you're
just cranking it out that's there's
nothing wrong with that no shame in that
and I actually personally per you know
when Sharon and I went broke I did all
kinds of stuff while I was rebuilding my
real estate business at the time I mean
I made money from fourteen different
things like you said because I would
just rather be doing something than the
activity stimulates your creativity it
stimulates a future opportunities and it
changes your mindset and sometimes it's
more than a little bit humbling I
remember one guy was an executive he was
trying to get out of debt and he was
delivering pizzas at night and he
delivered a pizza to someone that they
just hired it has come
was gonna report to him yeah that's one
boy yeah that is that is but what's
interesting too I love this idea of
maybe you start something because the
one thing I would say Dakota if you've
never thought of starting your own side
business or small business what I'm
recommending right now Dave in this
business landscape is you're looking at
business differently you're not thinking
of what is my dream business I want to
do it I love this is a long game play no
we're talking how can I make money fast
you don't love it you're just trying to
turn a profit quickly so what services
can you provide what knowledge can you
monetize I'm not even telling people
don't don't even worry about getting
into products based businesses with cost
of goods and inventory all that right
now today with your idea a Facebook page
with what you know what you can do you
know there's people that still need
landscaping there are people that still
need deliveries there are people that
still need that people are still buying
some things that you can start a
business that meets a felt need right
now today and you're like Dave saying
probably gonna make more than you would
at maybe working for a grocery store or
certainly unemployment so you've got
anything to lose and you can do all of
it that's right now what you were saying
I mean it's so yeah you can do the
caught the one-two punch of the
combination of all of its so the good
news is Dakota I I know and Christine
knows from having done this a long time
that just the fact that you're asking
the question means you're gonna be okay
that's saying you're not paralyzed
you're not in the corner sucking your
thumb you're not saying this just
destroyed my life I'm a victim of
circumstances you're saying crap I got
furloughed that sucks okay what if I
gotta do next next up you know yep and
the next man up next man up you know and
just and you step in and you know you go
ahead and you do that kind of a thing
hey good question